we do have Levon aronian it's been 12
rounds but finally you got the victory
in the tournament congratulations Levon
how do you feel right now
I'm Rel relieved because I think
you know not winning for so long can
damage here
mental system
uh so I don't think it was a game of
highest quality but
at this moment I will take any kind of
win absolutely especially going into the
final day against Fabiano caruana one of
your good friends but such a critical uh
game for the standings now let's talk
about your game against elshon take us
through the critical moment yeah I I've
played this line with black myself
against Lanier in American Cup and of
course it's a difficult line to play for
black uh very strategical and I think
Lanier played C3 also against me which
is another game you had to win you were
in a must win situation it's a very
tricky move
have to say because there's no C3 yeah
because it's basically white is waiting
and you can't really play for C5 because
then DC this uh yeah it's a bit too
early yeah this Knight D4 stuff is
very very dangerous from black
so you need to make a useful move and
you actually don't have yeah I think I
also played Princess seven I don't
remember yeah
we don't see it right here maybe I play
the A6 something like this yeah
and yeah I thought the G5 is a bit
premature now this Knight F1 looks very
very bad for black and what is the plan
behind this maneuver uh what I want to
do is play Knight G3 and you know
whenever I get the chance to just plant
something on H5 so get the night out and
then get age 392 and or Bishop D3 and
then try to put something exchange yeah
the lights for the Bishops and get the
Knight to H5 yeah and I felt that this
is I mean this is logical that he tries
to but it should be a bad position just
a bad end game in the position yeah I I
think I just made some mistakes around
here yes
my understanding of this maybe is not
good so I I felt this is a very good
position for why that the computers I
see yeah because it's unclear from a
practical perspective it does feel like
you have more space more weaknesses to
work with yeah so Bishop yeah I thought
that Bishop E7 there has to be a move
maybe I should have tried for rookie C3
I saw this in Knight B8 uh and I felt
Rook B3
and Rook C7
and I I was thinking mainly about Bishop
D3 here but then I wasn't sure I can
break through if he just castles Castle
yeah yeah it's it indeed Pleasant
because in this structure when you take
on G6
you can remove the Knight let's say 92
and play G4 it's very very pleasant and
you'll start to play with H4 this G4
move is very typical for the structure
right inside and try to get to H6 and it
really
cuts the Black Knights out of the play
yeah but but he didn't see the exact
breakthrough no I thought it might end
in a draw you know
so I saw this Rook uh B3 Knight B6 uh
but you know from distance I blundered
that if I take on C6 so Bishop C6 Rook
C6 a rook C6 BC Bishop B4 okay this is a
beautiful chippo this is for uh yes sir
of course but
yeah then I take on the three yeah yeah
but the problem with the this line that
after Bishop before moved number 22.
he takes takes
uh King D7 Knight D2 this all looks good
but this bishop C2 is probably
giving him enough contemplate no more
Knight B3 well if you're gonna yeah
Knight F1 then Rook B8 it's very precise
and 935 yeah and he's in time yeah and
you cannot take on B6 because B2 is
singing at the end yeah you're actually
just losing this one very nice so yeah
you decide to go for A4 yeah I I knew
that this is
probably nothing but well definitely
some pressure it seems like yeah at
least confirmed by 700k
yeah I saw that uh after Knight B2 I was
planning to play uh
I was thinking to play Rook A1 but I
thought this is probably equal
kind of rookie eight and then he chases
my Rook with very precise play yeah yeah
okay it rugby seven maybe right C4
things of this nature so maybe I
shouldn't have taken on S7 yeah
seems like Bishop to C3 was the best I
saw this move but I felt that you know
if he goes Rook B8 I got a seven
ah so Knight B2 takes takes place yeah
yeah I didn't believe in this somehow I
thought black is too active but maybe
yeah probably a wrong assessment from
from me yeah and the Knights don't seem
to have a clear path to get back into
the game so yeah I was a bit worried
that this is just going to end in a draw
as well from afar this is not easy to
assess for sure all right and he took on
A7 and yeah it got lucky here and I
managed to play 92 and yeah
you maintain your Pawn he doesn't get to
it and a nice conversion and see you
Levon congratulations and important
victory for you tomorrow with the black
pieces against a player you know so well
Fabiano caruana how are you going to
approach that one
I think the goal is uh you know just to
stay solid
and see what uh
you know game dictates it's not really
I'm I'm not having a great term but you
know last round has its own
rules absolutely always a pleasure to
play spoilers also if you're having a
bad event you might as well try to mess
up the other players congratulations
any questions no our congratulations
Lavon and we'll be looking forward to
your game tomorrow